[Musique]
l'homme est là dans le salon de la
nonciature de berlin il est là debout en
face d'un prêtre en soutane
il est là grand 1 m 86 blanc le type
même du grand à rien blanc si fort à la
mode dans ce temps de la terreur
hitlériennes
et il est là pour demander une chose une
seule rencontre et le nonce rencontré le
représentant berlin de pie xii le pape
du corps et le prêtre sentir pourquoi
voulez-vous voir le nom parce que j'ai
quelque chose à lui dire quelque chose à
lui révéler et tout à coup cet homme si
solide si athlétique
si fort en apparence ce trouble
l'émotion le cesi oui je veux lui parler
lui dire ce que j'ai vu de mes yeux le
massacre là-bas à l'est des juifs de
milliers de milliers de juifs tous les
jours tous les jours des hommes des
femmes des enfants de l'aider vue je
peux tout lui dire lui raconter comment
ça se passe personne ne le sait il faut
que le monde le sache il faut que le
pape le sache et ils crient maintenant
et ses mains tremblent et hors de lui et
sur le visage du prêtre c'est de la
méfiance et à mesure qu'il répète qu'il
veut parler que le monde doit savoir que
le pape doit savoir et bien la méfiance
du prêtre fait place à de la réprobation
etes-vous soldats
demande t oui je suis soldat alors vous
devez partie partir tout de suite
nous n'avons pas le droit de recevoir
des soldats monsieur partait je vous le
demande
partez et l'autre stupéfait
et bailly anéanti va obéir s'en aller
cet homme là le premier qui est à même
de dénoncer le génocide le massacre des
juifs de révéler dans quelle condition
il s'opère cet homme là s'appelle courte
guerre cheetah il est ce tome fureur ss
mais oui vous avez bien entendu est un
ss qui veut révéler le génocide mais
enfin pourquoi comment
c'est toute la question justement que ce
soit un ss c'est peut-être logique parce
que cette époque dans laquelle il vit
c'est le paradoxe perpétuelle il fallait
peut-être que ce fut justement ss
peut-être aussi est-ce le symbole de
l'incohérence de cette époque de notre
siècle l'histoire de courtes gâche
taille et très peu connu
peut-être entendez vous ce soir son nom
pour la première fois
vous allez voir qu'il faut connaître
l'histoire de courtes guerche taille
c'est un rhénan mais si lena minstère
s'il a grandi avec sa famille et
prussiennes et cela explique d'ailleurs
l'éducation assez dur qu'il reçoit la
maison son père est un vieux magistrat
procès il le répète à rien et le petit
corps gâches ta n'est plus à dos il que
ses frères et soeurs il est le sixième
de cette enfant et tout enfant c'est une
gouvernante qui l'attirent à dieu parce
qu'on ne parle pas beaucoup de tueurs
maison et puis quand il fait ses études
d'ailleurs brillante laisser universités
écoles polytechniques et bien il sent la
nécessité de se rapprocher des jeunes
est d'apporter aux jeunes ce qu'on t'a
que la plupart n'ont pas chez et il
devient animateur de mouvements de
jeunesse chrétiens dans le cadre de son
église qui est l'église évangélique
église protestante naturellement il est
adoré déjà il les réunit grandes sorties
randonnées débat on adore on est fasciné
c'est le mot que ces jeunes plus tard
emploieront nous étions fascinés
[Musique]
et notamment il va camper avec ces
jeunes près de cette forêt de sapins qui
existe toujours
[Musique]
et alors et de laquelle on a construit
la courte guerre stein house une maison
de jeunesse ou des spécialistes
réunissent depuis des années des années
des documents des témoignages sur
l'huile sur sa vie 1931 il est ingénieur
des mines mais toujours il s'occupe de
mouvements de jeunesse 1933 hitler au
pouvoir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et il faut bien dire que les églises
protestantes d'allemagne vont admettre
hitler ces églises protestantes ont
toujours aimé l'autorité elles ne l'ont
pas trouvé cette autorité pendant la
république de weimar et la salue avec
hitler d'autant plus qu'on ne sait pas
très bien ce que donnera l'hitlérisme
égard stein lui même ne le sait pas très
bien puisque il adhère en mai 1933 mais
oui lui toute carte stone y adhère au
parti national socialiste parce qu'il
aime aussi l'autorité
on sait pas très bien ce que ça donnera
le programme du parti
national-socialiste
personne ne sait ce que c'est c'est en
brume mais c'est vague
alors on peut supposer que les
nationaux-socialistes les nazis feront
bon ménage avec les chrétiens on peut
l'espérer du moins mais très vite on
s'aperçoit que c'est pas du tout c'est
que veut il est d'abord il la com et
sciences pour ces églises protestante et
il va créer une nouvelle église
protestante l'église des chrétiens alma
a servi
au national socialisme
et il va faire élire l'évêque de cette
église qui s'appelle muller et qui est
un ami voilà l'église nazis et
malheureusement au moment des élections
pour élire sept évêques les trois quarts
votre bruit alors voilà qui me plaît pas
gatx taille et quand gerstheim y apprend
que l'on va supprimer tous les
mouvements de jeunesse kg 1 800 mille
jeunes qu'on va les absorber dans la
jeunesse hitlérienne de baldur von
schirach le führer de la jeunesse
allemand le chef de la pitlane
[Musique]
alors merci talent n'est plus d'accord
et pourtant ils s'inclinent il fait un
discours assez jeune et l'ordre
au traité de versailles qui a humilié
l'allemagne ils étaient convenus que
nous devions livrer notre flotte de
guerre aux vainqueurs et déjà les
anglais à scapa flow était là pour
l'enlever l'emporter l'emmener avec eux
et à ce moment là on a vu le drapeau
allemand s'est levé au mas de tout dans
la vie on a entendu le deutschland über
alles hausse
[Musique]
et nos marins ont sabordé leurs bateaux
qui ont coulé famille euros alors nous
nous préférons scapa flow à versailles
c'est beau les magimel mais dans le même
discours
garth stein affirme son attachement
inconditionnel à notre vénéré führer
adolf hitler et oui c'est contradictoire
mais tout est contradictoire
cette époque-là on s'auto la gare stein
travail
ingénieur des mines il descend dans la
mine
et pourtant ces jeunes ils les
convoquent chez lui de temps à autre
pour des leçons de bible et un jour un
espion de la gestapo sa tête assez jeune
et son rapport est terrible gâchis stein
sous couvert de leçons de bible conseils
à ces jeunes de ne pas obéir au chef du
parti si ces chefs donnent des ordres
contraires à la doctrine chrétienne
alors on l'a à l'oeil à partir de ce
moment là on ad'autant plus à l'oeil que
j'ouvre la jeunesse hitlérienne faire
présenter une pièce une pièce anti
chrétiens et il est là dans la salle lui
qu'alger stein avec à la boutonnière son
insigne du parti national socialiste
mais totalement encerclée de nasion
uniforme
permanence fnath savez stand cheville
maroc en a fumé menetou salon cuisine
voyant des images et sourire et disert
l'entraînement on est habitué
et lorsqu'il y à une réplique qui
attaquent graves sans risquer niche kg
il se dresse et 17 insultant pour notre
foi nous n'avons pas le droit de tolérer
ça
[Musique]
résultat tous les nazis lui tombe dessus
il a un oeil abîmé et plusieurs dents
cassées
il est contestataire c'est évident mais
ce contestataire et membre du parti
alors contradictions encore ou tactique
si c'est une tactique
eh bien nous allons voir que plus tard
cordier stein n'appliquera un niveau
beaucoup plus grandiose encore être dans
le parti pour justement être libres de
critiquer davantage est de se trouver à
l'abri de son adhésion
c'est peut-être ce qu'a trouvé courte
guerre jetaient alors c'est le temps où
l'église justement n'approuve plus tout
autant qu'au début et au sein de
l'église protestante il y a maintenant
des gens qui n'acceptent plus ils se
réunissent dans une église qu'on va
appeler l'église confessante et parmi
eux il ya le pasteur niemöller
qui est tellement opposants qu'il finira
par être arrêté et maintenant face à
face le parti et les églises alors nous
savons que en ce temps là est bien
courte castagnettes un homme qui ne
tient pas en place
il agit avec une sorte de fièvre il fait
sans choses à la fois aucune minute de
détente à 6 il aime plaisanter elle nous
aimons qu'il aime plaisanter
et c'est justement une plaisanterie qui
va lui coûter très cher la sar après un
plébiscite vient d'être attaché orages
et on l'envoie à sarrebruck pour
préparer le premier congrès des mineurs
allemande façon de dire ben voilà nous
sommes chez nous et nous les allemands
maintenant de nouveau
[Applaudissements]
alors il lui prépare sa part ailleurs
pendant des mois le moment vient où il
doit envoyer les invitations et les
billets de chemin de fer aux gens qui
sont convoqués et certains avec leur
invitation trouve un petit mot places
réservées dans un compartiment pour
voyageurs accompagnés de chiens enragés
ou bien trouvent place réservée dans un
compartiment de malades contagieux
cette innocente comme les autres il y en
a qui a créé sa en souriant il y en a
d'autres qui protestent et qui le
dénonce à la police
alors la police fait une perquisition
chez cordguard stein et découvre mille
enveloppe avec dans chaque enveloppe des
brochures religieuse qui critiquent
sévèrement le régime pour sa politique
anti chrétiennes et il n'ya là d'autres
encore 7000 prêtes à être envoyées dans
lequel les brochures ne sont pas encore
insérés alors c'est grave c'est une
attaque à l'état envers l'état on
l'arrête
c'est comme ça et il est en prison il y
a immédiatement des interventions de
l'église de son père
le vieux magistrat qui se multiplient et
on le libère au bout de six semaines
mais là on l'exclût du bar
et ça c'est très grave à cette époque là
et on va le voir seul is it et sa
réintégration en partie vrai
[Musique]
et nous avons des lettres de lune qui
sont de lamentables autocritique vous
savez il faut dire les choses
je n'aime pas les héros tout d'une pièce
ils ne sont pas humains seuls et ils ne
sont pas authentiques bas celui ci il
écrit des lettres qui nous consterne
il dit je suis animé rien personne plus
que moi j'admire et ne vénère adolf
hitler il faut me croire
ces brochures elle n'était chez moi que
pour que je laisse détruisent tout ça
n'est pas vrai mais la vérité nous la
savons par une phrase une lettre à sa
famille ma famille me force au mensonge
et oui c'est le père qui est derrière
lui n'a pas envie d'écrire ça mais le
père veut qu'il soit dans le parti alors
il est sorti il est en liberté
mais il cherche
il s'est fiancé il s'est fiancé avec la
fille d'un pasteur
elle s'appelle helfrid il semble qu'elle
fried et courtes ce soit aimé
profondément et en 1937 il va épouser l
frais mais où va-t-il
il se console avec la religion il écrit
des brochures qu'il imprime à ses frais
il a des revenus
heureusement les revenus d'une
entreprise familiale dans laquelle il a
des parts et il parle dans ses brochures
uniquement il écrié il parle il fait des
conférences aussi aux jeunes de dieu de
la religion pas un mot dans ses
brochures 10 et conférences de politique
et pourtant va l'arrêter de nouveau
sommes en 1938 pourquoi il est accusé
cette fois de conspiration pour le
rétablissement de la monarchie
en fait il a simplement fréquenter des
jeunes gens puissants mallard schiste et
on se rende apercevra rapidement
n'empêche qu'il est en prison à
stuttgart et qu'il est transféré dans un
camp de concentration à vail siamese
découvre ce qu est un camp de
concentration en régime hitlérien et cet
affreux
[Musique]
alors une sont dans une véritable
dépression il ya une lettre de son père
qui décrit cette dépression il a perdu
pied il coule et on trouvera souvent ces
réactions chez courte guerre stein il
rencontre dans son temps un manque de la
gestapo qui le prend en amitié et qui
veulent faire sortir mais il n'est plus
qui sortent de l'eau qu'humaine quand il
sort il faut qu'il fasse un voyage il va
à rhodes pour se reprendre
il passe par venise est en route il
écrit à un oncle qui l'a en amérique en
lui demandant s'il pourrait l'accueillir
en amérique avec sa femme parce que
vivre en allemagne n'est plus
supportable est tout de même une rente
en allemagne et c'est le temps des
trilles on sait le temps de l'alsh tous
l'autriche absorber
c'est le temps de la slovaquie de munich
où l'europe entière est au pied du père
et voilà le père le vieux père qui
triomphe on est une lettre de lui mon
fils je suis fier d'être allemand notre
bien-aimé fureur à donner à l'allemagne
une grandeur qu'elle n'a jamais connue
réjouissons-nous monfils réponse du fils
elle se résume un signe non mon père il
n'a pas de quoi se réjouir
et il est lucide alors il a toujours
cherché à être réintégré dans le parti
et à force de réclamations
d'intervention du père on supprime
l'exclusion que l'on change en
congédiement alors du coup ils trouvent
tout de suite une situation en turin et
il va y travailler deux ans et puis
c'est la guerre les victoires
la pologne la france
et en août 1940 une fois de plus courtes
gerstheim demande à être réintégré dans
le parti nazi
est ce l'effet une attirance commune à
tous les allemands les victoires la
gloire d'hitler ou bien est ce toujours
effets de sa tactique
j'inclus à pencher pour la deuxième
explication
mais hitler lui poursuit son chemin
en 1940 on décide que les malades
mentaux qui se trouvent sur le
territoire du reich seront éliminés
alors dans tous les hôpitaux
psychiatriques on va chercher les
aliénés que l'on déclare incurable
qu'est ce qu'on en sait et on les amène
dans 300
alors l'art par fournées de 15 ou 20 on
les conduit dans une salle
hermétiquement closes
on leur a donné des somnifères ou de la
morphine pour qu'il soit mort et puis on
ferme la porte et on les gaz à l'oxydé
de carbone
le grand organisateur de cette hécatombe
c'est un officier de police qui
s'appelle wirth
alors on annonce aux familles avec une
lettre attristé que le malade a été
enlevé par une brusque maladie et pour
éviter les épidémies on a brûlé tout de
suite son corps et on peut venir
chercher l'urne quand on voudra et
justement en février 1941 la belle-soeur
de courte guerre stein qui volent mer et
la famille reçoit la lettre et on va
chercher l'urne et en février
on va enterrer ce étions dans la
sépulture de famille toute la famille
est là et personne ne sait ce qui s'est
passé mais courte d'erstein le sait lui
parce qu'il est très introduit dans les
églises et les églises savent et quand
la famille c'est cool après la cérémonie
il pas et il dit à ses frères et ses
soeurs
voilà où ils en sont ils tuent il
n'écoute même pas le commandement du
seigneur qui a dit tu ne tueras point
alors puisqu'il en est ainsi je vais
entrer dans les ss alors les frères et
sur leurs gardes
c'est une même très bizarre mais non
pour lui c'est logique et il va s'en
expliquer auprès d'un pasteur de ses
amis qui en a témoigné et qui a raconté
oui là il m'a pris par le bras
cependant que nous sortions du cimetière
et il m'a dit il faut qu'on sache ce qui
se passe ces gens là sont capables de
tout mais ils agissent à l'abri d'une
muraille infranchissable
nous ne savons pas nous ne savons rien
ce n'est qu'en intégrant parmi eux qu'en
étant moi même et c'est ce que je
saurais je vais devenir ss pour pouvoir
témoigner et dire au monde ce que
j'aurais vu avant l'entrée dans la ss
monsieur catane a fait deux visites chez
moi il m'a dit tu ne comprendra pas ce
que je ferai maintenant mais ne perd pas
confiance à moi c'était tout le mari et
je lui ai dit ma confiance en toi n'est
pas fini et je crois aussi maintenant
jusqu ici qu'il est magie dans les ss
pour faire son travail comme un espion
de dieu c'était sa croyance ne qui l'a
rangée de faire comme ça ce n'est pas
parce qu'il est curieux ou parce qu'il
est et je ne pense pas cette méthode là
non et il voulait chercher la vérité
c'était sa croyance en un dieu en jésus
christ tu lui as ça lui ce chemin si
c'est incroyable mais c'est ainsi et ici
ni il s'engage au mois de mars 1941 le
voit la ss vous allez me dire c'est même
étonnant à l'homme qui a été deux fois
en prison qui était dans un camp de
concentration qu'on a exclu du parti
bah oui vous savez c'est ça dans toutes
les administrations même administration
éclaire yens
alors sept mois de classe
il est bien longtemps et comme il est
ingénieur à l'issue de ces places on le
nomme aux services de désinfection des
ss il s'occupera de l'eau potable et de
la chasse à la pérennité de ces terres
accepté mais au point un appareil
intéressant dans ce sens
au puy vivre
il sera nommé ch tourner sur rss il vit
très bien noté on a ces notes on les a
retrouvés en face de tous les postes on
trouve erguner goodyear goods are good
très bien très bien très bien très bien
il a laissé un bon souvenir à ses
camarades s
certains le trouvent un peu trop
autoritaire un peu trop brutale
il est le type même de l'officier ss il
sera aux berges tome purin il suit il
suit très bien la ligne jusqu'au jour
jusqu'au jour où ses amis eux mêmes le
voit change plus dans le cadre de
service il est autoritaire et brutal et
plus quand ils se retrouvent avec ses
amis on le voit angoisses et ses amis
disent ils changé à vue d'oeil c'est
vrai il est taillé par l' angoisse parce
que ce qu'il voit c'est un système qui
détruit l'homme et pour lui qui est
croyant l'homme a été créé à l'image de
dieu et il ne supporte pas qu'on
détruise l'homme et pourtant il exécute
son service il n'exécute bien il sait
cette allemagne national socialiste et
tout à coup tout à coup courte guest
star
va entrer dans l'histoire l'un de ses
supérieurs il s'appelle gunther lui fait
savoir qu'il faut partir pour colline
près de prades et l'a chargé à bord d'un
camion 100 kg d'acide précis qu assez
précis
la voilà qui partent et à kolin lusine
charge en effet 100 kg d'acide précis
que sur le câble
il est avec gunther dans une voiture qui
précède le camion et avec un professeur
de faculté professeur d'hygiène qui
s'appelle fall in style
alors on roule et on arrive à lui bhl
est là on va trouver le fameux capitaine
de police verte oui celui de
l'euthanasie vous souvenez des lits
manade mentaux et bien oui en août 1941
un évêque catholique enchères a dénoncé
le massacre des malades mentaux est
comme hitler ne veut pas d'ennuis
il faut que tous les efforts soient
consacrés à la guerre eh bien on s'est
arrêtés on a arrêté la salle des malades
mentaux
comme quoi la protestation publique
pouvait servir à quelque chose
alors verte était libre et on va le
consacrer à une autre tâche ces
contretemps
les fameuses lois de nuremberg sur les
juifs ont été singulièrement des
passants
dès l'invasion de la pologne on a
concentré les juifs dans certains lieux
dans des camps dans des ghettos mais
aucune indication sur ce qu'on va faire
d'eux
cependant dès que les armées allemandes
sont entrés en russie de gigantesques
massacre de juifs ont commencé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dès qu'on entre dans un village dans une
ville ont réuni les juifs en dehors de
la ville on leur fait creuser des fossés
et là on les exécute elle y est
rieuse et affole les portons sur
d'autres corps on achève même pas les
blesser et puis on a inauguré du système
plus rapide parce que les soldes a
commencé à dire que c'était trop il ya
des rapports d'officiers nos soldats
commencent à avoir la nausée
alors certains eu l'idée de camions de
camions diesel simplement brancher le
tuyau d'échappement l'intérieur du
camion qui était hermétiquement fermé on
chargeait des juifs là dedans et nous
connaissons un go leiter qui avait cent
mille vivent sur son territoire
que faire rapport admirable ce qu'il dit
vous comprenez ça c'est tellement plus
pratique
rendez vous compte avec trois camions
seulement j'ai réussi à me débarrasser
de la plus grande partie de mes cent
mille juifs tuent l'artisanat
quelquefois en grands métiers de
l'artisanat
alors on n'est plus parce qu'en janvier
1942 à vannes c'est on l'a décidé la
solution finale de la question juive que
justement c'est dans le cadre de cette
solution finale que cordiale stein est
un jeu blanc et s'ils trouvent là le
capitaine wirth c'est parce que le
capitaine wirth est chargé de
l'exécution de la solution finale et lui
explique qui a maintenant trois camps
qui fonctionne la belgique et on va y
aller tout de suite un autre à saïda
un troisième à treblinka
il y en a même un quatrième à maidanek
qui est en cours de construction
belle si on arrive à voler
et gâche temps ils ne voient une voie de
chemin de fer qui arrive
il ya deux quais de part et d'autre de
la voiture match et puis quand on
s'avance on voit le portail
avec une pancarte entreprises ss de
belzec
cadieux on entre et puis voilà une
grande barque à gauche sur cette baraque
qu'on voit une porte avec vestiaires un
peu plus loin un guichet avec au dessus
du guichet valeur et puis plus loin
encore une autre baraque avec coiffeur
et puis ensuite un chemin
un long chemin en plein air 150 mètres
de long de part et d'autre des barbus
au bout de ce chemin quelque chose dira
guère stein qui ressemble à un
établissement de bains
et puis des pancartes avec des flèches
vers les bains et les inhalations et
puis de part et d'autre de la bras qu'on
forme d'établissement de bain des fleurs
et il a compris qu ashton qui n'auraient
pas compris s'ils n'avaient pas compris
l'odeur l'odeur pestilentielle qui
s'élève de ce vaste terrain aurait suffi
à tout faire comprendre me n'y a
personne n'y a personne à belzec
et on lui dit demain 7 à 7 heures du
matin il est là elle 7h10 le premier
train vient se ranger lentement entre
les deux
45 de marchandises bien sûr avec ses
fameuses petit plus qu'à fermés par des
barbelés et gars tu as une voix assez
petite fenêtre des enfants
apeurée terrifié qui au regard
et aussitôt une vingtaine d'ukrainiens
rentrer arrache les porter à coups de
cravache font sortir les gens ils sont
plus de civils dans ces quarante cinq
wagons
et on s'aperçoit qu'il y a des morts
parce qu'ils étaient très serrés pendant
le voyage il n'avait pas avoir mis à
mort et on en comptera 16 150 qui sont
morts pendant le voyage
alors les autres on les fait avancer un
coup de cravache isofrance femmes hommes
enfants et on nous parle
bienvenue à l'établissement ss de bell
vous êtes priés d'en lever tous vos
vêtements d'enlever vos prothèse
d'enlever vos lunettes de les déposer
aux vestiaires d'enlever vos chaussures
il vous sera distribué une ficelle qui
vous permettra de lier ensemble les
pères de choses
alors voilà tout se trouve lamentable
qui obéit les voilà tous nus
et il y un petit enfant qui a de la
ficelle dans les mains qui est là et qui
distribue la ficelle aux autres qu'ils
réunissent leurs chaussures les femmes
dos ils sont poussées chez le coiffeur
hiyala sanchez et derrière des coiffeurs
qui coquelicot picot voilà toutes les
femmes et toutes les jeunes filles le
crâne totalement dénudée et garth stein
demande à un ss mais pourquoi l es et
suis dit c'est pour quelque chose dans
les sous-marins qu'on réunit les cheveux
mais c'est vrai et c'est vrai car on
retrouvera plus tard un rapport qui
indique qu avec ses cheveux on faisait
des pantoufles en feutre destinés à
l'équipage des sous marins évidemment
gâches ta ne pouvait pas le savoir
et pour ceux qui mettront en doute son
récit est bien pour leur répondre
cette histoire de sous marins c'est
suffisant comment voulez vous gâche t
elle vante une chose pareille ne sait
même pas alors maintenant c'est fait les
voilà prêts mais il s'avance dans le
chemin
qui conduit à l'établissement de bains
et quand ils arrivent là devant il ya un
grand et c'est ce qui leur parle avec
onction un peu comme un prédicateur ne
soyez pas inquiet il ne vous arrivera
rien pénible simplement au moment de
l'inhalation je vous recommande de
respirer à fond parce que cette
inhalation est excellente pour les
branches elle luttera contre les
maladies contagieuses qui sont la plaie
de nos camps respirez à fond alors il ya
des naïfs qui lui demande mais monsieur
qu'est ce qu'on va faire de nous ils
répondent les amis vont travailler à
construire des routes ou des maisons les
femmes seront occupés aux soins du
ménage et de la cuisine il y en a
peut-être qui le croient mais combien
les autres ont compris depuis longtemps
comme en aurait-il pas compris et
l'odeur et l'odeur
alors tous ces hommes ces femmes et
aussi les enfants se mettent à prier
[Musique]
bravo
oh
[Musique]
morgenstern est là devant eux
il les regarde et il pleure et il prie
ils prient avec tous les maux qu'il peut
trouver dans son enseignement chrétiens
avec ceux qui me viennent mon dieu il
prit le dieu des chrétiens pour ceux qui
prient le dieu des juifs il sait que
c'est le même et un moment il dit non
mon dieu je ne peux pas laisser ces gens
je ne peux pas laisser faire ça je vais
aller avec eux il à la tentation de
s'engouffrer dans la chambre de la main
[Musique]
démunis et puis tout à l'heure quand on
ouvrira les portes au milieu des
cadavres il y aura le cadavre d'un
officier ss hondura accident étrange
accident
ce sera classé nul n'en parlera non je
dois rester vivant pour aller dire
ailleurs au monde ce qui se passe ici et
il pleure il prié maintenant ils sont
enfermés là dedans et on ferme la porte
[Musique]
ea les autres qui n'ont pas encore
trouvé place qui attendent qu'ils seront
de la 2e journée ils sont nus alors on
entraîne derrière la baraque
l'établissement de bains et lendu montre
un moteur diesel mais qui ont ou vont
directement dans l'établissement de
bains et wirth tous contents il y voit
là à l'aimer tel moteur en marche et le
mécanicien mais le moteur en marche
enfin voudrait bien le mettre en marche
parce que le moteur ne part pas rien à
faire le moteur ne marche pas alors
virta cours furieux du mans face est
incroyable et les minutes un quart
d'heure une demi heure une heure et d'en
imaginer ces gens pressés qu'ils
appellent au secours qui étouffe qui
pleurent qui crie qui supplie et lui
gerstheim qui est là et il la regardait
le au moment où on a fermé la porte
ça n'est que deux heures 49 après qu
enfin le moteur se met en marche et on
voit de l'oxydé de carbone dans
l'établissement de bains et gerstheim
regardera encore sa montre il faudra 37
minutes pour qu'ils soient tous ma
[Musique]
si on ouvre la porte ce sont d'autres
juifs qui ont provisoirement
l'aviso qui vont tirer leurs
coreligionnaires dehors et là avec des
crochets en faire on arrache les dents
or ici on explore les anus et les vagins
& wirth montre dans des boîtes de
conserve à gerstheim les dents en or les
bijoux les biais dit vous savez pas tout
ce qu'on peut récupérer il ya des kilos
d'or pouliot voilà ce qu'il a vu à peine
sec
y'avait le professeur se veut se
distinguer professeur de faculté
enfin lynch t-il alors lui pendant tout
ce temps là c'était la mouche du coche
s'intéressait beaucoup donnent très
curieux comme aspiration puis un moment
donné pendant que le moteur ne partait
pas il était allé regarder par la petite
fenêtre y en avait une pour qu'on voit
on pouvait allumer d'ailleurs de
l'extérieur pour voir un peu oui en été
et il a dit en pleurs 1 c'est comme la
synagogue voilà ce qu'a dit le
professeur pfannenstiel le lendemain on
sera très bling et l'on verra la même
installation en plus grand et après
cordiaux stein repas pour berlin or lui
ayant dépassé les limites de l'horreur
et décidés à dénoncer cette horreur au
monde entier alors oui j'ai dit qu'il y
a des gens qui ont mis en doute ce récit
d'abord on a dit qu'il avait fêté
fabriqués après la guerre on a retrouvé
les manuscrits du récit des graphologues
ont analysé l'écriture qui est celle de
guerre stein sans aucun d'eux alors
wirth et ben il sait il a été tué par
les partisans à la fin de la guerre le
groupe n sur eure lui s'est donné la
mort mais le pr l'excellent professeur
van schil on l'a retrouvée après la
guerre et on l'a interrogé nous avons
ses interrogatoires il ne dément rien il
a été à belzec
avec cordiaux stein n'est pas
l'établissement exactement comme
cordiales stein il a vu fonctionner
comme cordguard stein avait pourtant
pourtant ils protestent violemment dit
non non je n'ai pas fait cette
plaisanterie regrettable je n'ai pas dit
qu'il pleurait comme à la synagogue
sans commentaire non
alors voilà la nuit le train qui roule
de varsovie à berne
des wagons-lits cordiale stein dans le
couloir il n'a pas trouvé le coucher
on
et un autre homme dans le couloir c'est
le secrétaire de l'ambassade de suède
le baron von goethe
et fondateur racontera qu'il a tout de
suite compris que ce grand et c'est ce
qui était la voulais lui parler alors
rue cigarettes du feu on entame la
conversation est tout de suite car je
tiens lui dit est ce que je peux vous
dire quelque chose de terrible oui tout
ce que vous voulez voilà j'arrive d'un
camp qui s'appelle belzec
et voilà ce que j'ai mon impression de
claudia stein été et est encore qu'il
était tout à fait sincère ligne de voix
qu'il était un idéaliste suis en forme
religieux et que c'était son but sur
l'espoir que par l'intermédiaire tant
pis neutre ce crime jeu sera terminé
avant notre longue entretien entretien
qui a duré cinq ou six heures comptera
sur l'appareil tout à fait incroyable
peut être serait très à stresa les
équilibres en tout cas au début mais il
il se came à la civic
j'ai essayé de faire une sorte
d'interrogation contradictoires pouvait
réveiller sa crédibilité
il a fait des esquisses du village de
bergeyck j'ai demandé des références et
il a mentionné le nom de docteur
tiberius un homme que j'ai rencontrés
par hasard quelques semaines après à
berlin et débutera côté que grâce à la
publicité
un ou deux jours après notre retour à
berlin qu'il avait raconté exactement de
même histoire et aussi son entretien
avec moi alors j'ai fait mon rapport
alors que l'ambassadeur ainsi en détail
mais et demandant si je devais faire un
rapport regrette alors il m'a dit que je
ne devais pas faire le rapport écrit
mais à la portée des événements pendant
une visite à stockholm
j'ai fait quelques semaines plus tard et
la suède qui est au courant ne fait rien
et ne dit rien pourquoi
et bien parce que la suède est le seul
dernier pays du nord de l'europe qui ne
soit pas ou occupés ou alliés force et
l'allemagne hitlérienne
alors il faut ménager hitler alors
c'était il est à berlin
dachstein il appelle son ami peters qui
est à la luftwaffe viens viens viens
tout de suite qu'il parle à peters toute
la nuit et il pleure ensemble peters et
affolé dit non non mais quoi comment est
ce possible
qu'allons-nous faire que pouvons nous
faire et ils décident qu'ils vont le
dire à tous les gens qu'ils pourront
aborder et va frapper partout car je
taille il ira chez voir le nonce du pape
cherché à voir le nonce du peuple vous
vous souvenez et le petit prêtre en
soutane lui agnel vous en messieurs
allez vous en alors on est tenté de se
dire mais c'est un crime d'avoir chassé
cet homme
elle ce crime ce ss à la nonciature
est-ce que logiquement ce collaborateur
du non ce ne pouvait pas se dire qu'il
s'agissait d'une provocation
on pouvait tout supposer le côté exaltée
de gerstheim ajouté à la supposition
mais cela pose tout de même le grand
problème du silence de l'église
catholique ou plutôt du silence de pie
xii
ce silence dont on a tant parlé qui a
fait l'objet d'une pièce célèbre le
vicaire dont vous vous souvenez de jouer
dans le monde entier et il est vrai que
pie xii n'a élevé eu aucune protestation
solennelle contre le massacre des juifs
contre le génocide et le problème se
pose toujours aujourd'hui
j'ai longuement étudié cette question
c'est à fait j'ai consulté les documents
et à mesure que je lisais ces documents
je balançais d'un côté ou d'un autre
tantôt je me disais il fallait qu il pas
et puis quelques heures après je conclus
et ils devaient se tait l'église
catholique a sauvé des juifs
beaucoup en europe mais par des
opérations ponctuelles des interventions
localiser on estime qu'au moins deux
cent mille juifs ont été sauvés par les
la hiérarchie catholique est d'ailleurs
après la guerre heures les juifs ont
remercié beaucoup et 12 einstein gold
amer bien d'autres
mais fallait-il parler les raisons de
pie xii
elles sont multiples il a pensé que s'il
s'exprimait par une proclamation
solennelle le remède serait pire que le
mal est il est vrai qu'en hollande par
la hiérarchie catholique avait pu
négocier avec les occupants allemands à
propos des chrétiens d'origine juive
alors été égale les nazis conçoit
baptisés ou non mais là on avait pu
négocier et les juifs devenus chrétiens
pouvaient se réfugier dans les couvents
puis un beau jour on a enlevé tous les
juifs violent et alors là les évêques
hollandais ont protesté solennellement
résultats les allemands sont allés
chercher dans les couvents les juifs
chrétiens alors s'appuie 12,2 savait et
se disait qu'il valait mieux agir en
détail et obscurément et ne pas lancer
une proclamation solennelle ne pouvait
dont on ne pouvait pas mesurer l'effet
et pourtant cela manque aux chrétiens
que pie xii n'est pas parler
probablement ne devait-il pas parlé mais
disons le cela manque aux chrétiens
[Musique]
mais par ailleurs qui frappait à toutes
les portes garde
et justement il voyait le coadjuteur de
l'évêque catholique de berlin c'est
comme cela que le vatican a été alertée
et puis il voyait un diplomate de
l'ambassade de suisse et nous savons que
la suisse a été alertée que le rapport
est parvenu à berne mais nous avons le
témoignage de ce diplomate suisse qu'est
ce qu'a fait la suisse m'a rien parce
que la suisse était la voisine de
l'allemagne et que le danger était trop
grand et nous savons même que la suisse
hospitalière on réfugié politique aux
prisonniers de guerre évadés
c'est fermé
le texte est là il ne faut pas
accueillir de gif terrible
[Musique]
egan stein a averti un correspondant
hollande est un ingénieur qui faisait
partie de la résistance hollandaise qui
a envoyé le rapport allons et qu est ce
qu a fait long les américains ont su et
puis que vous commencez à savoir
d'autres rapports venaient de partout
souvenez vous vous qui comme moi écouter
la radio anglaise est ce qu'on vous
parlait souvent d
alors pourquoi encore cécile 1 cordell
hull
le secrétaire d'état américain ayant su
ces informations prescrit une enquête
elle est longue cette enquête soit dure
des mois et pendant ces mois ont oui on
enquête à la diplomatie n'a jamais
espace un million de juifs même
[Musique]
hautmont
et puis enfin tout de même on décide de
protester s'allier font un communiqué
tom pas très bien communiquer pourtant
quand même du côté américain on commence
à s'inquiéter
entrevue avec les anglais et là anthony
den répond oui on pourrait peut-être
obtenir en négociant avec des neutre
qu'on nous livre ses juifs mais
attention faudrait savoir ce qu'on veut
en faire la palestine pas question a pas
de problème avec les haras on pourrait à
la rigueur en prendre quelques dizaines
de milliers mais alors s'il y en a des
millions qu'est ce qu'on en fera mon
cher dit anthony den à son interlocuteur
américain mon cher ya un problème de
tonnage que nous ne devons pas oublier
nos bateaux sont réservés aux matériels
ne pouvons pas distraire du tonnage pour
ces juifs à pia aussi raison c'est que
du côté américain notamment
on sait que hitler présente cette guerre
comme la guerre des juifs est clair le
répète sur tous les tons et goebbels
alors lebel se répète et bien oui cette
guerre était déclarée par les juifs
c'est une guerre que font les juifs
contre le national socialisme
et si on parle trop des juifs est bien
on aura un petit peu l'impression de
donner raison hitler alors on en parle
le moins possible à l'orgue erstein
frappe aux portes sans apport appel il
avertit des centaines de personnes qui
en avertisse d'autres et aucun résultat
cet affreux mettez vous à la place de
cet homme qui courent des risques
immenses parce que il est suivi il est
espionné tous les allemands sont
espionnés
quand il est sorti de la nonciature y
avait un policier qui a suivi cette es16
qui venait d'entrer chez le représentant
du pape qui a voulu savoir et à ce
moment-là guerche tania sorti son
revolver pour se donner la mort ne
voulais pas tomber ville entre la main
ces gens là il savait ce qui l'attendait
les tortures pendant des jours et des
jours et il aurait parlé
et puis le policier finalement abandonné
sa filature et depuis il avait toujours
sur lui un revolver et une capsule de
cyanure pour se donner la main il est à
bout de nerfs
en 43 ses amis le voient maintenant avec
les cheveux blanchis
il
saab a littéralement sous le poids de ce
fardeau qu'il porte sur les épaules il
est malade psychiquement
physiquement le diabète le range l'été
2009 144 en mission alcine qu'il doit
être hospitalisé il revient chez lui en
allemagne à berlin est de nouveau
hospitalisé
[Musique]
il va quitter berlin
vers le 15 mars 1945 sa famille est à
tübingen sa femme et ses trois enfants
où il a trois enfants maintenant
courtiers achetaient
et les alliés approche
il annonça sa femme dans le courant
d'avril dans la [ __ ] tu entendras
bientôt parler moi
et il a littéralement se jeter dans les
bras d aller justement la zone où ils se
trouvent
ce sont les français qui sont et il va
se présenter aux commandants militaires
français ait ling eluard
est le commandant le croit elle il faut
que vous écriviez tout ça c'est trop
important et il est libre il a même un
laissez passer dix ans le titulaire
n'est pas un ss comme les autres il faut
le ménager
alors il est à rod vaille dans un hôtel
est il écrit d'abord en français ensuite
en allemand c'est de rap
et puis il rencontre le 5 et le 6 mai
des officiers américains et anglais leur
mère doublure à pas et on s'aperçoit que
ces anglo saxons sont au courant des
chambres de mort et on s'aperçoit qu'il
le questionne les premiers il dit mais
c'est vrai ces chambres gars là pour
naturellement je les ai vu un détail
très important dans cette histoire
pourquoi at-on envoyé appel sec gov
taille et bien c'était officiellement
pour accélérer la désinfection des
vêtements parce que ses vêtements il
fallait leur distribuer aux populations
notamment réfléchi mais c'était aussi
pour étudier l'emploi d'un gaz plus
rapide et plus toxique que l'occident de
gamin d'où cet acide prix sic que
gunther l'avait chargé d'emporter avec
lui mais cet incident possible qu'il a
déclaré en arrivant qu'il était
inutilisable qu'il fallait mieux
l'enterrer
mais il ya quelqu'un que ça contrarier
cette arrivée de berstheim c'est le
capitaine wirth
le grand patron de la mort à tous les
étages et virton reconduit zangerl stein
lui ai dit vous n'avez que faire un
rapport sur vos gaz toxiques
nous on ne demande qu'une chose c'est
continuer
voilà le rôle de gâches ta
alors il écrit tout cela en france et
l'europe hors france et manuscrits en
allemand le rapport allemand est
dactylographiée sur la machine à écrire
d'un pasteur je fais partie en 46 de la
délégation française au procès des
criminels de guerre l agneau lombaires
et donc j'ai étudié là j'ai vu là
nommément de document est un document
qui a tout spécialement frappé mon
imagination parce que l'histoire
à première vue par le sabre semblables
il s'agissait d'un essai ce qui avait
été un en titre ayant convaincu qu'ils
avaient été mis dans des camps de
concentration en temps de paix par les
nazis et encore je me suis mis et qui ce
bouquin sur les atrocités nazies qui
s'appelle le brier al de la haine alors
j'ai écrit simplement au ministère des
affaires étrangères de suède demandant
si ce que racontait que ce raid était
vrai et j'ai reçu à ma satisfaction est
un petit peu à mon étonnement une
réponse circonstanciée disant que tout
c'est absolument vrai et puis il écrit à
sa femme
tout va bien mais on vient me chercher
c'était la fin de mai
le 26 mai carrosse on vient me chercher
pour me conduire à constance levé sans
doute comparaître devant des gens qui
seront heureux de savoir tout ce que je
sais je suis l'un des rares à connaître
la vérité mais à constance ne semble pas
très intéressé par ces déclarations et
les officiers américains dans leur
rapport d'hier curieusement les français
n'ont pas l'air du tout intéressé aux
révélations du sr ce dur gitaï bizarre
ce monastère
en tout cas les français le transfert
appareils
il est gardé quelques temps dans les
locaux de la sûreté une file juste et
puis ont les crocs la prison du cherche
midi la plus vieille le plus antique des
prisons de paris ces cellules d'insectes
grouille de vermine
en couchant un sac de sang on a un saut
en tout et pour tout pour faire sa
toilette
autre chose on ne mange pas me faire que
par celles parues dimanche cette époque
et il apprend qu'on va l'inculpé comme
ss pour assassinat et complicité
d'assassinât
ainsi voilà à quoi il a abouti voilà à
quoi aboutit cette mission qu'il s'était
donnée à lui même
voilà à quoi aboutit c'était fort
psychique immense de paraître un
excellent ss tout en étant chez les ss
pour dénoncer l'inimaginable
il a risqué sa vie mille fois il a cru
qu on l'accueillerait comme l'agent du
destin et on la cupe
gomes pour assassinat et complicité
d'assassinât
un matin le gardien qui ouvre la porte
de la cellule korpi hashtag le découvre
pendu
on fera venir les médecins qui
concluront au suicide est ce que coderre
stein avait lui pascal pascal qui disait
je crois aux témoins qui se font égorger
lui il s'était égorgé lui-même
on l'a inhumé au cimetière de thiais
et puis quelques années plus tard on a
nivelé la partie du cimetière où se
trouve sa tombe il n'y a plus aucune
trace en seconde de courte guerre gitaï
[Musique]
et même en 1950 un tribunal allemand de
dénazification condamnera courdier
acheté à titre posthume on reconnaît
qu'il a résisté mais on juge qu'il a eu
tort de rester dans les ss après avoir
découvert ce qu'il avait vu au camp de
belzec
en 1964 le président de l'état de bade
wurtemberg monsieur kissing le
réhabilitera condamné réhabiliter encore
une contradiction la vie de khouribga
stein sera décidément tissé de
contradictions c'est pour reprendre la
formule de saül friedlander auteur d'un
beau livre sur lui
l'ambiguïté du bien mais pour moi ce qui
domine c'est cette image du schtroumpf
l'urss pour gerstheim au milieu des
juifs nu qui marche à la mort et qui
pleure et qui pris avec eux c'est
l'image du showroom fureur ss cours de
garches taille qui a voulu alerter le
monde devant le massacre le seul
massacre scientifiques étaient conçus
dans l'histoire c'est l'image du juge
tombe fureur ss courte guerre stein co
le monde a refusé d'entendre
et qui en émanent
[Musique]